la prison depuis des années moi ce que
j'entends c'est que c'est réinsérer
c'est éviter la récidive c'est le
confort dans les prisons la France est
sanctionné machin et nous merci citoyens
français tout ça il en a rien à cirer
des sous-titres
citoyens qui ont voté qui ont causé du
tort à la société madame
c'est compliqué Pierrot oui déjà est-ce
que vous en pensez de ça
c'est fou dans la merde non non mais la
réalité c'est que il y a rien qui va
dans le système carcéral français enfin
non mais est-ce que les les parce que la
question c'est est-ce que les détenus
sont des sous-citoyens ils sont pas des
sous citoyens il y a une catégorie de
détenus qui peut être considérée comme
des sous-citoyens c'est ceux qui ont été
privés de leurs droits civique par
décision de justice là en effet si on
prend l'étymologie ce sont des
sous-citoyens parce qu'ils ne peuvent
pas par exemple voter ou se présenter à
des élections mais la réalité c'est quoi
c'est que on a des prisons qui sont
surpeuplés parce que on a des mers qui
refusent de construire des prisons
je voudrais statut parce que sa phrase
elle est quand même forte de sens
Mathieu Delormeau tu vas nous dire
sûrement je voudrais avoir la vie de
deux un ou deux oui déjà Raymond
qu’est-ce que tu en penses non c'est pas
des il a été trop fort il est en
réaction par rapport à ce que lui dit la
la dame qui est en face de lui elle lui
dit c'est des sous citoyens et lui dit
oui évidemment que non que c'est pas des
il y a les peines faut prendre en compte
il y a des vols
bah oui bah il a été trop loin bien sûr
qu'il a été trop loin ce que j'étais en
train d'expliquer il était beaucoup trop
loin parce que ça dépend des peines pour
moi des mecs comme Nordahl Lelandais
tous ces grands tueurs en série et
fournir et compagnie pour moi c'est des
sous citoyens et c'est des merdes est-ce
que tu avais dit ici voilà je voulais
déjà dit maintenant il y a des mecs qui
sont là-bas parce qu'ils ont volé des
voitures il y a des mecs qui sont là-bas
parce qu'ils ont pas de permis il y a
des mecs qui sont là-bas parce qu'ils
ont fait une connerie et du coup ils
attendent purger leur peine alors c'est
quoi la solution c'est moi j'ai
énormément mon ami qui ont fait des
conneries qui se sont insérés qui
maintenant font énormément pour rien et
qui font qui aide beaucoup beaucoup de
gens et dont on a énormément besoin et
qui sont vraiment des des amis proches
euh alors je voudrais encore un ou deux
oui Mathieu bah non j'aimerais dire
Géraldine que la prison c'est c'est
comme être SDF ça peut arriver à tout le
monde et sans prévenir donc je te parle
pas d'être violent d'enfant ou de
Monsieur assassin mais une petite peine
de prison ça peut être un moment
d'égarement ça peut être une colère ça
peut être ça peut être un permis
effectivement parce que tu as pas le
choix que tu devais travailler pour
nourrir ta famille et que ta conduite
sans permis ça peut être plein de choses
qui font en sorte que tu vas en prison
tu vas payer ta peine en prison c'est
masque que tu as fait mais tu n'es pas
un sous citoyen du tout pour autant et
c'est vrai ça m'étonne que ton mari et
qui est un homme intelligent j'en suis
sûr mais tu fais et puis faire ton mari
et puis faire un amalgame aussi
important oui mais finalement un vieux
alors d'enfant et quelqu'un qui est
voilà qui récidive sans permis et qui
fait de la prison non ce sont pas
laissés citoyens parce qu'il sait pas ce
qu'ils ont fait une faute donc voilà ils
sont hors de la société unino oui il y a
des fautes des grosses fautes des
petites fautes Géraldine tiens ton mec
un moment donné s'il sort et qu'il est
fatigué tu dis reste à la maison on va
pas la mission mais on sent bien que les
mots ils ont dépassé leurs paroles on
dirait Gilles en plus beau ce que je
veux dire
on sort on sent que c'est nous on
dépasse sa pensée il y a pas de l'étape
suivante c'était quoi sous homme tu vois
sous humains alors elle va répondre
après Gigi c'est pas la première fois
que tu sors une petite Béatrice
Daniel je suis pas patient pour le
besoin ils disent qu'ils pour ça alors
lui il est pas ouais avec la première
partie de ce qu'il dit c'est vrai qu'on
en fait trop pour on pense pas assez au
victime on pense toujours à améliorer le
confort des détenus maintenant ceci dit
il faut savoir que les détenus dans les
prisons comme vous l'avez dit c'est
surpeuplé ils sont franchement il y a
des rats ils sont dans des conditions
indignes vraiment indigne et c'est pas
l'honneur de notre pays de faire ça et
quand il dit sous citoyen là il va trop
loin parce que du coup ça semble
justifier toutes ces conditions qui sont
déplorables et indignes et indécente et
il faut quand même faire la part des
choses il est allé trop loin sur la fin
sur la deuxième partie ça c'est sûr
Delphine tu es d'accord avec Daniel
Riolo oui parce que pour moi aujourd'hui
les citoyens de la République ont des
droits et des devoirs et quand on dit
liberté égalité fraternité on est égaux
lorsqu'on respecte et lorsqu'on ne viole
pas la liberté de l'autre lorsqu'on ne
viole pas la fraternité lorsqu'on ne
vole pas l'autre Nord lorsqu'on ne le
tue pas donc je suis désolé lorsque tu
es en prison c'est que tu as fait
quelque chose de mal faut arrêter de
toujours retourner là-bas donc on te
laisse
on peut tous faire un truc voilà on en
parle comme a dit qu'on m'a dit Raymond
bien sûr on parle pas de Nordahl
Lelandais on parle pas de fournir et on
parle enfin voilà non mais des gens
voler des gens faire des vols à
l'arracher et tout je suis désolé quand
tu vas en prison c'est un peu une
punition donc on restera tes libertés
cultiver tu peux apprendre des trucs
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait il se douche
plus
moi je trouve ça je trouve ça
franchement je trouve que là il a été
beaucoup trop loin Daniel
voilà vraiment la CC c'est c'est c'est
c'est fou mais pas vous non moi ce qui
m'énerve avec cette petite phrase qui
tourne sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
qu'on l'a sorti de son contexte en fait
qu'est-ce qu'il dit Daniel rideau il dit
que tous les prisonniers ne sont pas
pareil on peut pas comparer quelqu'un
qui a commis un petit délit et quelqu'un
de bêtises il a dit sur des soucis
citoyens pour moi désolé arrête de
défendre l'indépendant arrête-toi
arrête-toi pas toi tout citoyen arrête
pas toi arrête pas mais on l'a dit si on
l'a dit ici voilà donc
il a pas dit il a pas dit ça il dit pas
de bêtises alors à la fin à la fin tu
entends ce qu'il dit il dit voilà le cul
de de d'entendre parler des prisonniers
il a dit au début
c'est la même rhétorique et après Gilles
Verdez non mais Daniel Riolet très
intelligent Guillaume il sait exactement
ce qu'il dit donc il est en robe mais il
pense que les prisonniers sont des
sous-citoyens et c'est inadmissible
parce que mais après après après c'est
voilà ce que qui veut dire etc c'est que
le truc c'est voilà c'est c'est que lui
il a dit un petit peu comme Raymond mais
il a fait la phrase à l'envers donc
derrière aussi un truc aussi qui nous
est arrivé ceci c'est que parfois tu
vois un truc sur les réseaux c'est comme
chez nous combien de fois on s'est fait
comme ça ils mettent un truc ils mettent
un extrait c'est la folie partout et
derrière ils sont pas bu ce qu'on a dit
avant et après donc je savais pas ce
qu'il a dit avant par exemple regardez
tout en entier ça part sur le contre
internet il dit qu'il y a des il y a des
prisonniers certains prisonniers qui
devraient pas avoir internet parce que
il mérite pas ils ont fait des trucs
graves et d'autres qui méritent d'avoir
internet parce que c'est moins grave
comment tu fais pour mettre trois mecs
avec trois peines bon alors toi tu auras
droit à Internet et toi tu auras pas le
droit Internet dans la cellule comment
tu fais ça c'est ingérable on va pas
créer des cellules avec Internet et sur
Internet c'est c'est tout ça à l'envers
le truc Daniel toi tu penses est-ce que
tu as regardé toute la séquence qu'on a
dit Gégé parce que tout à fait vraiment
toute la séquence et je suis d'ailleurs
d'accord avec lui sur plusieurs points
donc mais en revanche il connaît le
poids des mots il sait que ça peut être
coupé sous citoyen je suis désolé
je le dis il va pas faire du buzz lui
non mais peut-être pas du buzz mais en
tout cas c'est très grave quand il dit
ça
d'accord
on entend ça et c'est pas possible même
pourtant Dieu sait que je suis très très
dur avec certaines personnes là c'est
pas possible sous citoyen ça ne s'entend
pas moi pour moi c'est pas audible
les gens qui l'écoutent il y a beaucoup
de gens en prison qui ne l'écoute le
soir sur RMC quand il parle football il
fait énormément de bien à beaucoup de
gens j'ai des potes qui sont en prison
qui me disent c'est le rendez-vous du
soir c'est la bouffée d'oxygène en
faisant ça il a insulté beaucoup de mecs
qui sont fans de lui donc c'est pas le
buzz en faisant ça échange Castaldi je
vous ai pas entendu là mais c'est la
réponse est simple on est prisonnier
mais on a des droits donc on n'est pas
un sous citoyen c'est simple que ça
ouais mais tu as des droits que tu es en
prison sous citoyen ça veut dire ça veut
dire quoi en fait ça veut dire que tu
étais 50%
on est considéré comme des sous-citoyens
ça veut dire qu'on nous dénit le droit
d'être réinséré c'est en sac pour moi
cette phrase elle est extrêmement
choquante quand on est en prison
d'ailleurs énormément de prisonniers moi
aussi Jean qui nous regarde l'émission
C'est le soir exactement voilà donc
c'est pas du tout des sous-citoyens
c'est des citoyens qui ont fait une
erreur une faute et qui ont droit à un
avenir donc cette phrase elle me choque
énormément alors Géraldine tu veux
internet pour que ça va tu veux internet
ton ordal Lelandais non mais c'est pas
ça
quand même on parle pour l'ensemble des
prisonniers
donc il parle effectivement le thème
c'est effectivement internet en prison
est-ce que il faut que les prisonniers
et Internet en prison et la femme qui
parle Emmanuel Dancourt qui est très
brillante dit elle a priori oui elle est
d'accord pour tous les prisonniers et
lui dit maman moi je suis pas d'accord
parce que qui quoi comment c'est à dire
est-ce qu'on va donner la comme il
disait à un je sais pas un pédocrinel
Internet est-ce qu'on va donner un
théoriste Internet il mélange tu
mélanges tu dis
je répète ils n'ont pas le droit d'avoir
internet sans penser qu'ils sont des
sous citoyens la société elle a raison
Béatrice qui a choqué on ne peut pas
dire aujourd'hui
ça veut dire qu'ils n'ont ils sont ils
sont mis hors la loi et comme l'a dit
très bien des fines en ce sens ils n'ont
pas les mêmes droits que ceux qui sont
morts
pour pour l'ensemble des hommes
et même
de ce fait ils se sont exclus de la
société ils ont décidé d'être hors la
Horde hors de la société et c'est pour
ça qu'ils sont en prison qu'est-ce que
tu penses de des explications ils sont
c'est complètement vaseux ils sont
privés de liberté Géraldine ils sont
privés de liberté
et pourquoi parce que ils ont fait une
faute une erreur et donc il doit donc
ils doivent d'abord ils doivent
privés de liberté ce sont des citoyens
qui ont été jugés et donc ils ont voté
sur les citoyens qui ont fauté voilà
c'est tout ils sont pas des sous
citoyens on est d'accord qu'en prison
ils sont quand même enfermés ils n'ont
pas le droit par exemple d'aller venir
s'il vous plait s'il vous plaît ce sont
des citoyens qui sont qui ont fauté
voilà sauver ce sont des citoyens ce ne
sont pas des sous citoyens ils n'ont pas
les mêmes droits que les citoyens qui
sont en prison
c'est pas un sous-entend c'est un enfant
qui est puni non mais qui va qui va
voilà qui va être puni qui reviendra
ensuite tu vois ce que je veux dire non
mais merci de me faire une explication
texte je comprends très bien ce que tu
dis mais c'est pas mal ce qu'il dit mais
malgré tout pour moi sous citoyen c'est
encore une fois c'est pas sous homme ou
sous race en fait
citoyen civique c'est quelqu'un qui n'a
plus de droit civique donc il n'a plus
rien à dire dans la société
[Musique]
tu considères les terroristes comme les
sous-citoyens gilberté
si tu considères les terroristes comme
les sous citoyens c'est pas moi par
exemple je considère l'été
Gilles Verdez non donc excusez-moi moi
je considère comme des sous-citoyens ils
sont privés de leurs droits civique tu
as le droit de les ça n'a rien à voir
parlez pas de ça
des terroristes vous avez vu la séquence
avant non mais il parle des pédocrinels
et des terroristes non mais désolé
les prisonniers sont des sous citoyens
c'est voilà c'est voilà il y a plein de
prisonniers qui nous regardent il faut
dire ce sont pas des sous-citoyens voilà
je suis désolé ce sont des citoyens qui
ont sauté
les terroristes exactement les gens les
gens les gens dans les prisons c'est pas
les terr chez les pédophiles comme ça
effectivement c'est c'est assez choc je
suis d'accord mais sauf que ça vient
dans un contexte où je trouve que c'est
très clair moi personnellement
et Delphine n'est pas amoureuse non plus
oui est-ce que je peux juste revenir sur
ce que Mathieu a dit c'est à dire quand
un enfant fait une bêtise ok c'est pas
sous-entend mais en fait un enfant c'est
un mot tu vois commun puis un adulte
c'est un mot commun mais le mot citoyen
c'est pas tout à fait un mot commun
c'est un c'est un statut tu comprends
c'est un grade et tu l'acquières si tu
rentres dans c'est un citoyen de la
République donc
voilà
ton grade de citoyen de la République
Géraldine si on parle du terme citoyen
il y a à peu près 98% des prisonniers
qui ont le droit de vote ils peuvent
voter par procuration on pense même
peut-être installer des urnes en prison
pour les grandes élections donc le mot
citoyen ils sont des citoyens puisqu'il
vote après justement on l'entend plus
tôt comme sous homme on est tous à peu
près dans la même dans le même esprit
donc il a voilà il semblait penser quand
il s'est énervé qu'il l'a dit c'est ce
qu'on a vu dans ses yeux mais on peut se
tromper non moi je trouve pas mais après
vous avez le droit de le penser ça me
dérange pas
évidemment elle le connaît mieux que
nous qu'est-ce qu'il y a Gilles à
travers vous me parliez des terroristes
mais dans Sous citoyen on entend sous
hommes on entend alors
arrête avec les terroristes
à la raison Géraldine pour les
terroristes
citoyens ça veut dire non non
c'est possible
c'est pas pour ça que tout le monde
découvre non mais c'est vrai voilà
faut arrêter les mecs moi j'ai
énormément de potes en prison
qui rêve de se réinsérer qui nous
regardent tous les soirs donner leur
bouffées d'oxygène je pense très fort à
eux voilà et à plein de gens qui nous
regardent qui ont fait les petites
conneries voilà bah oui c'était ils ont
pas été voilà ils étaient dans un milieu
social difficile ils ont fait une
connerie le regrette ils sont en train
de purger leurs peines et ils ont qu'une
envie derrière c'est de se réinsérer et
de et de et de revenir dans une vie
normale et au contraire de faire encore
plus que ce qu'il faisait avant et
d'être encore plus des citoyens que ce
qui était avant et quand ils entendent
quelqu'un dire sont des sous-citoyens
ils le prennent aussi pour eux alors je
suis d'accord avec Géraldine sur
quelques voilà prisonnier comme on l'a
dit voilà mais Gilles Verdez là
Géraldine a raison tu peux pas tu peux
pas défendre les terroristes
qui ont été condamnés pour viol ou pour
crime et qui font du karting à Fresnes
excusez-moi les Français sont choqués
aussi ça vive la réinsertion mais pas
dans ces conditions oui pas n'importe
qui mais je suis très heureux moi qui ai
des prisonniers qui font qu'il fasse le
karting voilà tout ça ouais ouais je
suis d'accord avec vous pas les violeurs
ça voilà voilà on est on est d'accord
mais Gilles tu peux pas défendre quand
elle te dit euh est-ce que un terroriste
et un pédocrinel c'est un souci citoyen
toi tu dis NON je dis ce ne sont pas des
monstres mais c'est un vrai débat
[Applaudissements]
c'est quelqu'un qui fait exploser des
enfants d'une lâcheté mais qu'est-ce qui
t'arrive Gilles 89
que j'ai pour toi de côté là je suis
sérieux 2 minutes tu ne peux pas Gilles
comme ça sur un plateau de télé dans 2
millions de personnes dire que un
terroriste ce n'est pas un sous citoyen
voir un sous homme et que c'est
quelqu'un qui faut comprendre enfin
Gilles comprendre
excuse-toi pour toutes les victimes
c'est pas possible
toutes les victimes du Bataclan de tout
terroriste c'est pas un souci citoyen ou
un pédocrinel je suis désolé ils ont été
condamnés voilà donc c'est c'est parfait
qu'il ne sortent jamais de prison sans
doute mais quand on me dit ce sont des
monstres l'être humain je suis désolé je
suis pas pour la je suis pas pour
internet pour les pédocrinels et pour
les non plus
un monstre pour plein de prisonniers je
suis pour parce qu'il y a plein de gens
qui font des peines voilà ils étaient
des trucs et même des peines moi j'ai un
pote voilà je vous le dis c'est un et on
le connaissait c'est un super pote à moi
c'est un des plus grands braqueurs de
l'histoire de de France voilà on le sait
voilà c'est voilà il a fait 20 ans de
prison aujourd'hui dans l'arrière
insertion je peux vous dire lui voilà il
n'a jamais il m'a dit je n'ai jamais
brutalisé quelqu'un je faisais voilà
alors oui il a fait des conneries il a
volé il a plongé sa peine il a fait 20
ans de prison voilà il y a plein de
potes à moi voilà qui sont là aussi qui
purgent des grosses peines qui nous
regardent le soir qui ont fait des
conneries voilà ils ont mais pour eux
oui je pense que oui internet oui
pourquoi pas oui parce que voilà ce
qu'ils ont envie de se réinsérer ils ont
envie ils ont pas une connerie mais pour
les peaux criminels et les terroristes
je suis désolé on peut pas dire que ce
sont pas des sous citoyens pour moi ce
sont ceux des sous-citoyens parce que
moi dans toutes les familles du 13
novembre qui nous regardent ce soir non
mais après non là
j'ai condamné je suis pour qu'il sorte
jamais de prison
j'ai dit ce ne sont pas des matchs tu
peux pas dire ça ben voilà un pédophile
est un nom je suis pas d'accord
j'entends parfaitement pour moi un
pédocrinel est un démonstration
je suis désolé je suis désolé pour moi
je suis désolé
moi quand je vois la famille Nordahl
Lelandais que je vois la maman de de la
petite et le papa et que je peux le dire
pour moi bah c'est c'est une désolé pour
moi c'est un monstre internet d'ailleurs
grâce à Internet avec toi c'est pas un
monstre c'est bien internet dis-le c'est
un monstre ou pas il n'y a pas d'êtres
humains pour moi qui sont des monstres
c'est renier l'état d'êtres humains moi
quand on a tué une petite fille mais oui
et qu'on a violé pour mon amour je suis
désolé tout ce que vous voulez
ce que tu dis tu dis c'est renier l'état
d'êtres humains mais en violant ou en
étant un terroriste l'état d'êtres
humains mais il faut pas être comme eux
voilà ce que je dis voilà ce sont ce
sont des gens qui ont commis des actes
horribles mais les les les moi pour moi
les pédocrinels et des riches populaires
je peux pas moi avec tout le mal qu'ils
ont fait excuse-moi je les considère
comme des mots si je peux pas les
considérer comme des hommes dans
excuse-moi bah je te le dis bah voilà
on n'est pas d'accord là-dessus mais une
fois de plus tu sais et je te dis tu es
dans la en fait tu es dans dans la loi
tu es dans le dans les textes de loi
mais c'est c'est ça mais c'est ça ton
problème non mais qu'est-ce que cela
sont des chutes le roi civique donc
justice non cette fois-ci est bien faite
mais au-delà de ça tu dis non mais tu
lis pour toi personne n'est un étatiste
pour moi donc voilà les les
êtres humains qui commettent les pires
atrocités reste des êtres humains voilà
ce que je veux dire voilà voilà donc
c'est pour ça que je suis contre la
peine de mort ce sont des gens terribles
ce sont des gens terribles que je
déteste mais je ne leur enlève pas leur
état d'êtres humains c'est que c'est un
mot
je sais plus quoi dire en fait quand
j'entends gilbertez mais après je sais
pas pour de hier idéologique je sais pas
tu es tellement gentil bon
compréhensif bienveillant que il en
vient à dire des des énormités me
semble-t-il de mon point de vue je suis
à peu près d'accord avec toi là après
non mais c'est toujours pareil j'étais
avec quelqu'un la famille qui avait été
victime pas le même place des victimes
bien sûr mais moi aussi mais c'est pas
du tout mais c'est évidemment Cyril vous
comprenez bien bon voilà en tout cas
Daniel Riolo un jeu il sera avec nous
demain ah oui il sera avec nous demain
Daniel je sais pas si tu es au courant
Géraldine
si tu avais 10 minutes prévu demain
Daniel sera parce que
demain et on dirait donc voilà après
l'émission il y a eu un sondage et 75 %
des gens lui donnaient raison tu vois
bah à mon avis demain on va reparler de
la phrase de
je pense voilà mais bon après c'est
bonne chance sur Twitter
on a compris ce qu'il voulait dire
est-ce que tu peux expliquer ton propos
comme ça au moins voilà ces gens sont
atroces les gens qui ont commis des
actes terroristes qui ont attendé à la
vie ou à la dignité d'enfants c'est
abominable mais je considère qu'il n'y a
pas d'êtres humains auquel on doit
enlever le titre d'êtres humains donc
les considérés comme des monstres comme
des barbares et ça c'est un vrai débat
les mecs un vrai débat mais je suis
d'accord mais c'est un vrai débat mais
c'est pas du tout être contre les
victimes ils ont toute ma compréhension
il peut faire du kart dans la prison
hollandais non mais excusez-moi j'ai
jamais dit ça je n'ai jamais dit ça j'ai
dit que pour moi il n'y a pas de le
terme de Mons ça veut dire qu'on vous
renie le fait d'être un être humain donc
il y a pas de monstre en tant que tel
voilà même quand vous pourriez
excuse-moi franchement quand ton viol
une petite fille de 10 ans on est à
monstre excuse-moi d'accord
dans certains cas franchement c'est la
prison habite très bien moi j'aurais
beaucoup plus loin dans certains cas je
lui dis ouvertement vraiment je pense à
l'inverse de toi et des choses qui sont
inadmissibles un mec qui écrase 89
personnes
qu'est-ce que tu veux penser qu'est-ce
qui mérite ce monsieur là un mec qui
ronfle 89 personnes
franchement il fait quoi
il m'énerve
de Nice qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire de
lui je ne sais pas moi franchement c'est
un monstre absolument je te dis ce qu'on
fait alors je le tue moi j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] je le tue je te le dis quelqu'un
qui ressemblait terrasse citoyens
quelqu'un qui tire sur des terrasses sur
des gens pour rien faire qui était
heureux en tout cas des gens qui ont été
dans des concerts qui ont rien demandé à
personne qui se sont fait canarder comme
des chiens des terroristes qui font des
trucs comme ça des normales Lelandais
des Jonathan Daval qui crame ça face à
sa femme dans la forêt qui lui met des
baskets au pied pour faire croire
qu'elle a été courir moi je te le dis je
le tue le mec j'en ai rien à [ __ ] vous
pouvez m'insulter sur toute parce que
vous voulez ce mec là n'a rien à faire
sur Terre avec moi voilà c'est réglé
c'est fait c'est dit voilà
[Applaudissements]
pour moi parce que je t'entends mais lui
ce mec là c'est même plus un sous
citoyen c'est plus rien pour moi il
n'existe pas je veux pas qu'il revienne
dans 10 ans pour recommencer tuer une
autre gamine il m'intéresse plus je veux
plus à faire les courses avec lui je
veux plus le voir nulle part je veux pas
te payer en prison pourquoi je vais le
mourir en prison pourquoi les mecs qui
tire sur des mecs en terrasse qu'ont
rien demandé pourquoi je vais le nourrir
moi en prison avec les impôts des
Français allez ça dégage ça peut choquer
c'est mon point de vue peut-être ça se
fait pas de parler comme ça
[Applaudissements]
et voilà pourquoi il y a tellement de
lois à revoir et on espère que dans les
dans les prochaines années
[Musique]
quand je dis ce ne sont pas des monstres
je sais très bien que c'est une manière
de dire que je suis contre la peine de
mort qu'il ne faut pas les éliminer et
avec Raymond on a deux vues complètement
différentes mais je respecte entièrement
ce qu'il dit non mais donc
c'est un monstre il y a pas d'êtres
humains qui sont des morts impossible
parce que les monstres
dans 20 ans 25 ans il sera pas très
vieux tu trouves ça normal tu penses tu
penses à la petite Maëlys tu penses aux
parents tu peux comment tu joues là
mais arrête
d'espérer arrête d'espérer tu vois bien
il ne sortira jamais lors d'un Cyril il
ne sortira jamais quand
seront rejetées vous le savez très bien
pour lui du coup toute ta vie et sa vie
aussi ça te dérange pas de payer pour
lui c'est à dire que vous voudriez quoi
l'éliminer lors de Lelandais mais moi je
suis contre la peine
il faut tout faire pour les réinsérer
les gens qu'on pourra pas réinsérer et
dans ces cas-là en tout cas moi je pense
à tous les prisonniers qui nous
regardent ce soir qui ont été voilà et
qu'on sait des conneries qui ont envie
de seins qui ont qu'une envie c'est de
sortir et de reprendre une vie normale
et d'aider les gens et bah je peux vous
dire voilà j'espère qu'en tout cas ils
nous regardent qu'on leur fait du bien
et la phrase voilà ce sont pas des sous
citoyens en tout cas pour nous mais
c'est vrai que voilà et je peux vous
dire que les prisonniers qui nous
regardent pour eux normale Lelandais
c'est un monstre je vous le dis je suis
énormément de SMS faut dire que c'est
un monstre et c'est souvent je reçois
des sms qui sont beaucoup plus violents
quoi et qui disent au-delà au-delà de
pourquoi ils sont l'isolement ils y vont
là-bas en prison pourquoi il aime
beaucoup les mains d'isolement ce qui
aiment bien la raison il contient pas
c'est vrai